[Música]
que queremos justicia climática cuando
la queremos ahora estos son los miembros
de la generación fukushima hombres y
mujeres jóvenes que se reúnen en el
centro de tokio para exigir que se actúe
ante la emergencia climática
dentro de un momento los jóvenes
hablarán para proteger nuestro planeta
por favor escuchen luz
los manifestantes piden el cierre total
de las centrales nucleares de japón pero
el gobierno quiere volver a ponerlas en
marcha no puedo aceptar que volvamos a
poner en marcha una forma de energía tan
peligrosa es imperdonable
estaba en el jardín de infancia cuando
ocurrió el desastre de fukushima pero
recuerdo que fue aterrador la energía
nuclear es una carga para las
generaciones futuras incluidos mis
propios hijos tenemos que parar el
tiempo
mi ham en junio hoy en julio japón ha
reiniciado varios reactores en los
últimos 12 meses y otros 3 están en
construcción durante su primera
comparecencia en el parlament o como
primer ministro fue mi oficina defendió
la energía nuclear bajo la presión de
los diputados de la oposición para
lograr la neutralidad de carbono en 2050
es crucial que volvamos a poner en
marcha las centrales nucleares con la
aprobación de la población local y el
organismo de energía atómica de japón
como quinto emisor mundial de dióxido de
carbono japón quiere reducir su
dependencia del carbón y el gas que
juntos representan el 70 por ciento de
sus fuentes de energía para
japón quiere volver a poner en marcha
los reactores nucleares el gobierno
quiere que la energía nuclear genere el
22 por ciento de la electricidad de
japón para 2030 casi los mismos niveles
anteriores a fukushima a pesar de la
amenaza constante que supone la
posibilidad de otro gran terremoto o
tsunami